hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play blame alpha
build ok this is game on gamejolt that
people I've been bringing to my
attention so I wanted to give it a try
um you're some guy who has to make a
decision of some sort and that's about
all that I know about the game so let's
get into it man on the Unity engine if
any of you were curious about that so
let's see what we have here ok
ooh nice looks like some actual detail
into this level ok so we've got some
indentations and the walls not sure what
those are about um box is there nothing
important I don't think in to radio
looking things along as a battery e to
interact no to self the content must not
be completed ok in the three corrupt
data discs turn on the generators and
place them into the control panel this
will permanently disable the god said
okay what's the gods head notice Evan
the God said requires a sacrifice you
must find the teddy bear zeros and the
book what and on the generators and
place these items into the containment
chambers the gods head must be completed
wait a minute well there seems to be
some conflicting appearance huh things
here save them or finish it I wanna
finish it yeah screw them whoever they
are okay so apparently there's some
shiznit going down here and I think I'm
in a lab of some sort but these walls
definitely don't look very lab esque to
me okay so there's two choices these are
the choices that I heard about um you
can either ok lab 2 is over this way you
can either um save everybody by
destroying the gods head or you can use
get a teddy bear of something else in a
book and turn it on you could have ended
this I'm not so sure about that I
haven't done anything yet so don't make
presumptions do not presume anything ok
so I know I'm gonna get lost in here I
don't even have any glow sticks to
do anything with just a flashlight with
a really crappy battery I don't know
where these guys in these horror games
are getting their flashlights from but
they don't last very long at all I
should probably the batteries themselves
okay witty observations are now over act
to the game I gotta say it's actually
it's actually pretty nice I mean the
walls are pretty generic but at least
there's some semblance of an ambience
going on here with the sounds I am
hearing with the sounds I'm hearing and
definitely some work put into it so I
like it so far let's just see if there's
anything that's gonna develop from it
looks like my battery is about to die
will it automatically replace new okay
tab to get to the inventory use
batteries
what the hell what was that hang on what
is this why would I even need to use the
flashlight I can use this diamond vision
that I have here I'm just gonna walk
around like this kind of sets a better
atmosphere what's this over here ec
generator user wait do I need to turn
this on ah I wouldn't have seen that
okay one generator is on so hello what
are you a rose was that the other thing
that I needed and a disk okay so I got
the Rose in the disk and I needed the
disk to turn it off and I guess the Rose
to turn it on okay that's nothing there
huh
very interesting hello I'll get to you
in a second despite our best efforts we
are unable to trace the source of these
transmissions what trans but you don't
know where they came from but we know
that they come from entities that are
far more advanced than ourselves some of
the lab techs say aliens but I know any
messages from the gunner to aliens okay
um
oh that's just generate or I wasn't sure
what the hell that was okay so while I'm
getting some text from some people I am
going to continue moving forward I don't
know if there's a monster in this game I
would assume that there would be it
seems like the kind of halls that I
would be stocked in okay it's pointing
to EC lab - hang on let me go down I'm
trying to get because I don't know if
there's gonna be like a table with
something out in the open that I'll need
so I'm trying to go down every single
thing here what are the other pills for
anyway what is it what is all that for
counteracts the essence and heels can
raise my stamina okay I'm gonna walk
around in the dark because it's actually
easier to see with this in here not as
easy to see details but I can definitely
see the environment a little better
hello let's see if like who's that hello
is something out there I hear a lot of
noises just Wimbley wombly in the
darkness and these weird cabinets that
are just standing around
good hello is somebody there is someone
there I don't want any no thank you okay
so I'm not getting anything from these
cabinets other than just plain old
batteries in what have you I don't know
what else there is to offer me but huh I
honestly have no idea I'm thinking being
led in giant circles here because this
all looks the same there is no
navigation besides those signs that I
had wait you did this I didn't do [ __ ]
don't blame me for your mistakes maybe I
did do all this and if I did where's
everyone else who was helping out on the
team there said there were more than one
don't pin this on me oh god I get to it
a second huh
hey on my phone every time I get a text
it decides that if I don't pick it up
right away my hand then it automatically
means that I want I didn't get it at all
in these notify me Oh
over and over again okay you could have
ended this I haven't done anything yet
was that the same messages before am I
going in a circle now oh well oh wait
hang on that curves down definitely
haven't mad at a curvy rooms yet seems
like the noises happened more in the
darkness but I turn my flashlight off so
I'm gonna oh oh what's this what did I
get
what if again I got a Buch my notes for
activating the gods head so Dwight is is
that for what do I do about that is that
something else
wait what what did I just get I don't
know what I just got what what did I I
need to find this I got something don't
tell me I didn't yeah whatever okay all
right so anyway I can't tell what I'm
getting there so small babies cuz you
have your flash I've shot me I know
what's best I don't know what that is
we've decided the blueprints for a
device we're calling the god said Haley
the dis device will allow us the tap
into another plane of existence another
plane we're talking inter-dimensional
technology this is astounding
it is astounding anything I miss no okay
I'm just gonna use the flashlight seems
a bit easier and maybe when I'm in the
darkness I summon demons okay where's
this what is this how about that in here
no I have not question mark I can hardly
tell what's a new place in what's an old
place everything looks very same II
might just be a limitation of the assets
that they have in the union seriously
what do these is they're one because I
can't I'm not I'm not running as quickly
that says raise stamina it's ginseng so
let me just slam a bunch of those down
then I'll sprint like the winner huh
alrighty in another raah do some of the
boys in the a seat
abs are worried about the effects of the
essence if that's high I think they're
overreacting yeah a little written miss
is hardly anything to worry about
oh okay some of our crew have claimed to
be experiencing auditory hallucinations
we'll have to investigate no we won't
we're not gonna investigate we're not
gonna stop on our research wait a minute
oh did I just get all three discs yeah I
got three discs okay and I just need to
find I think that's a teddy bear that's
left so there's only one more generator
to turn on right there's three
generators three items three items total
of nine of everything if I wanted to do
all that jazz already been there Bulls
go let me go let me go let me go let me
go whoa where did that come from
whoa that was weird
where's does this occur okay this is the
Kirby always all righty then
that's how we're gonna be weird floaty
ghosty thingy duty is I think I need to
take this it's a more ginseng hmm oh
look wait what all the sudden everything
is lit up like de Janeiro's aren't
active ah crap what what what what I
guess when you take the Lucid pills it
makes you go all bright and shiny
I got cornered didn't I man I can't run
for anything I take those pills I still
can't run high yeah okay all right then
yeah dead end all right good good yeah
get away get away let me go let me go
let me go let me go there we go I need
to damn it that guy's all over me now
get away get away I need to find one
more one more lab but I can't I don't
know where I've been already this
doesn't help me need to get a new
battery for my flashlight hey you see
lab 1 I bend it three and two I think
and I think I need to get to one so
where is it is it over here no that's
another pathway to something else yeah
there's like a sign but it's 10 million
oh there it is
okay the signs are not adjacent to the
doors it's not helpful oh we never been
to whoo oh that's a teddy bear okay ah
all right let's listen to it I don't
want to be caught here when that thing
farm is now we've been receiving and
deciphering transmissions from an
unknown source these transmissions have
given us the blueprints to technology
far more advanced than anything we've
ever seen
once we're able to decipher all the
transmissions who knows what we can
achieve how about a God's head and
whatever the hell that means it's a
God's head the head of a god it's nice
mantlepiece gonna hang it in my living
room
it's gonna look real good okay that's
the last generator which means that I
can open the door to that other room
that I found over yonder way which means
that I probably have to encounter mr.
ghosty goo mr. ghosty goo are you out
here whatever the hell you are are you
part of the gods head
are you dead tingey that told us how to
build it
are you what kill everyone else in this
lab or was at me hi there you are okay
so I think I go this way and I'm gonna
shot these bad boys down and I think I
go this way and take a right no this is
wrong isn't it this is wrong this is so
wrong please be the curvy hallway it's
not Oh piss way TC zero isn't that what
I'm looking for isn't that what I'm
looking for I think that's what I'm
looking for
curvy Kirby car eh alright now we just
need to decide if we want to destroy the
world if we want to save the world not
save the world save the world okay so oh
it's dark in here let me just take
another loose it make my eyes go all
bright and shiny OOP oh it's so nice
okay so I either put the three disks in
and one less of these things the gods
demand a sack
yeah all this time they've been feeding
us technology giving us the answers what
are we giving them in return
nothing was spitting in their faces the
gods demand a sacrifice yes yes they do
where do I sacrifice them okay that's
where you wait that looks like a disk
insert I think that's where you put that
in I see three tubes here there anything
over here is this is a God's head looks
like an iron lung but whatever I'll wait
here
yeah kind of hurt I hope this is right I
want to summon the Godhead water water
water water what huh did I do it then I
destroy the world
we've reached the ec0 what's going on
the moon the bastard did yeah the
Harrises activated the gods head yes
he's activated to God said yeah they're
unusual amount of essence in here at
senators now he's not here sir wait
we've located a little Anthony's I'm
sending the medical team now no need sir
they're gone I'm ordering my men dairy
treat a meeting with the hills at
Christine Valentine report Valentine
okay something gonna happen
was that it what no kaboom I was
expecting an earth-shattering kaboom
yeah blame blame out nothing cuz I
didn't do anything okay that was
actually really well done I'm really
impressed by that so though that was
pretty good I mean the environments were
really really similar but there was
voice acting in there that was custom
environments and stuff the monster could
have been a little more work on the end
he wasn't really a threat to me he just
slammed down those bills and he's
nothing but either way I liked it a lot
pretty good amount of effort into it I
like the music in it I don't know if
that's made by you but if it is is well
done um could have been a more climactic
ending it was a bit anticlimactic the
world or something but anyway okay it
was great
I liked it check the description for a
link so thank you everybody so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye
oh no we go to runway